focus on your customer experience if you
don't have big budgets to spend on TV
ads on radio ads to really market your
business which I'm assuming you know
most entrepreneurs we don't have that
the best way to grow your business is to
focus on the customer experience make
them love what you do make them can't
wait to come back to experience it again
to tell their friends about you to talk
about you to share your website you have
to make your customer experience rock
solid because otherwise you're
forgettable and it doesn't matter how
much you spend on radio TV ads whatever
it is you're not going to get the
traction that you need with your
business it's going to be money wasted I
got a question from a reader shalina i
hope i pronounced that right shalina
wrote a crazy long message we need to
work on condensing our messaging anyway
long story short she she's a she's a
part time entrepreneur she wanted to
start an aerobics class was reggae soca
music teaching mom's as a way to dance
lose weight have some fitness in their
lives and she's had some success with
the first class and wants to grow it and
she's spending money on radio and flyers
and it's not working out once might help
wants to be able to make this a
full-time job and not have to you know
stay at her current business I've been
an employee and wants to know how to
make this thing fly so congratulations
this is a tough step to start a business
and it's great you ready have some
customers coming in I am an investor and
part owner in a dance studio here in
Toronto and we don't teach soca but
we'll teach salsa bachata kizomba
merengue cha-cha and we teach maybe five
six thousand people a year how to dance
and I get what you're doing it's a great
feeling to know that you're helping
somebody out that they're coming in
having a great experience dancing off
you know they're fat and and making new
connections and loving
their lives a little bit better here's
the thing that helped us a lot and that
can help you with your business to you
really need to focus on your customer
experience you need people to walk away
from that class feeling like it was the
best part of their week every experience
with your company has to be amazing
don't offer the same reggae soca class
that everybody else is offering you have
to step it up a notch what makes yours
so amazing unique and different because
you want the people coming back over and
over and over again but more importantly
telling their friends you said you're
targeting moms moms are one of the most
connected groups of any group out there
you don't need to spend money on radio
deals on flyer drops and I don't want to
see you wasting your cash because you
said yourself you can't keep continuing
at this pace the moms will tell each
other they love talking about what
they're doing and what's working for
them why aren't they talking about your
business it's not the promotion that's
wrong there's something that's wrong
with your classes and it's not that it's
bad I don't think they're going out
saying a this was a terrible class but
it's not great it's average it's okay
and we don't talk about I was your okay
things I don't tell my friends about
average you're okay things I don't make
videos for you guys about average you're
okay companies you have to improve the
customer experience make it amazing so
that they will want to talk about you
here's a few things that might help
here's a few things that we do that are
successful that may help you with your
company as well first off your website
your marking material has to embrace the
fun element right people coming for fun
everything has to be fun okay this is
not to learn how to socal learn how to
reggae or whatever it is it's about
having fun so your instructor has to be
fun your website has to be fun your
marketing has to be fun everything is
fun
step 2 from that first class when they
come in people are nervous the first
class if they've never done a dance
class before the nervous is not sure
what to expect again it has to be fun
it's not about teaching technique it's
about making them love the experience
and this applies for any service
business you have to provide an amazing
experience make them want to come back
make them feel confident make them feel
like they made a great decision and
they'll keep coming back structure your
outline of your courses with that it's
easy to learn they feel like they're
making progress people have come to our
schools where they've tried to learn
salsa before they've never been able to
pick it up but because of our
methodology because we make it so easy
to learn and so hard to fail that they
keep coming back and they love it and
they tell their friends most of our
business comes from people coming back
they start in level one and then go to
level two three four or five six
specialty classes different dances with
the school repeat customers and referral
business because that's the art classes
of the best part of their week and
they'll tell their friends I just went
to another class I feel great I'm
learning this new move I went to one of
their parties whatever it is they love
it people need to be talking about your
business like that and then the third
thing is try to add something on top of
just the classes to make it easy so send
them a list of the moves that they're
learning send them a video of the moves
that they're learning send them some
sample music that they can practice to
go above and beyond what's expected from
just a single class to get them talking
about your business so stop spending
money on radio stop spending one on your
flyers and invest in the customer
experience and it will pay off humongous
dividends for you and we'll let you quit
your job so you can focus on your
business full time I know it's hard
because the models out there may be
average
if you look what everybody else is doing
its average you have to come up with
something new you can model success from
the top guys or people in different
industries but you have to break out of
your comfort zone and think of new ways
to add a ton more value and when you do
that you have a lot more success from
reading your email and the enthusiasm I
believe you can do it you know you're a
hard worker you really want to make this
work you're creating it for the right
reasons and that will come through you
just have to focus your efforts on the
right places with your business belief
thank you everybody for watching if you
like this video please give it a thumbs
up below and I'd love to hear we get to
think leave a comment let me know what
you think let me know what you liked
about it if you didn't like something
let me know too and if you have a
question for your company leave it below
I'll make a video response thank you
I'll see you soon
you